[Music]
who am i
people just see an animal
they call me a savage
i'm the most vicious
ruthless champion that's ever been no
one can match me my thousand percent i'm
ferocious i want your heart i wanna eat
your children praise be to allah
is that who i am
whether i'm right
i gave you life
now you heading down the path of a
doomed child
[Music]
it's coming mike
it's coming
[Music]
i'm going to be the youngest heavyweight
champion in the world
you got to be the meanest fighter god
ever created
[Music]
don't you want to change your life and i
won't your superiority
will be undeniable
they'll love you as much as they fear
you
[Applause]
you better keep on with it
the second you lose they're throwing
your awareness out
this is all about immortality
about your name being known to the end
of time
[Music]
you're so desperate for someone to love
you you're right the minute you get too
big they gotta cut you down
but don't be that monster
be our king
if it wasn't the champ would still love
me
so who am i
[Music]
you